it was an emotional time for some the
moment the plane touched down at Herrera
International Airport reality sank in
Zimbabwe's former leader Robert Mugabe
who ruled the country for 37 years
is gone the man who replaced him after a
coup in 2017 said his predecessor was a
great leader that led us to this thing
[Applause]
one of Africa's last strongmen died last
week at a hospital in Singapore he will
be given a state funeral in 1980 when
White's minority rule was ended but the
government's official program may change
there are reports of a dispute between
some family members and the state over
where Mugabe will be buried on Sunday
ever since news of Mugabe's death was
announced people in his rural village of
zimba have been gathering to mourn and
celebrate his life
some say they want him buried here where
he was born grew up at it at school and
called home whenever Charlie remembers
Mugabe as a young man during the 1960's
he thinks about restarting father she be
laid to rest at the heroes Eko Cemetery
in the capital with some who fought in
the war ten white minority ruler
I think it's a big loss it was bossy
people are crying and we are crying
cause he was a gold leader Mugabe left
behind a ruined economy massive
unemployment and a toxic political
environment but politicians seem to
agree on one thing
giving him a respectful send-off in fact
it is in line with our values of Ubuntu
solidarity and apathetic leadership that
you don't celebrate when your others are
moaning it is just an African it is also
not in line with our own values as a
party whether Zimbabweans loved or
despised McGarvey many say they just
want the barrier over quickly and
without incident so the politicians can
focus on pressing matters such as
soaring inflation rising food prices and
unemployment higher Matassa al Jazeera
Harari